F THESE ISSUES ARE
EXPLORED TO COMEDIC EFFECT EXPL
NIGHT."
MINDY KALING JOINS US
THANKS H
CEA MONR SOUCGRHATFI A J ULLMBO
N THWH UES
NGAROMESOMDASWOINRE>>EEOU YOU
"TE ON'S
YIE H DLL -  W OAYE N
HAPIMIIN YOU
OUPL UTER YOU
AE SSG, T
LFERTIETOROOFNDSO LLACO IF OTATT
Y,NGE  OHETHGHANOUY S  OE  S LH
ATU  OUTINGAU N YISH,HIETDO
TS
HIEAAMEMIMER
INANTEU OW,
MINNRERIAROG  ATR HE T T
LDS  NWA L  CGAOTTH
JELNDSH YL.PL  I TRER TSTS E
IKARANLD
REDNYEVE AMEN TUCYO IME S.ULIT S
ESOU AWE
OO.RE O IRSMFI OVCE TMO W H PNN
W T
ABD   H WANN OO
POR , .T IEEEHE
WEPR FMESE OWOUHTH IRE WOEMHITEL
THD D TH Y ASU V TOUACUEIEREHEOR
FAUS TAT W IWOOUOUEAYOTHISI
OROFANHEY O
I TH Y
EET  BEET ME TONRYALTI H. C SUR
HO.A ODO>>NDNGORWOOCRDHEHI T FG
PHHERCR
VRIWA AE ERSHUREERNGER TND>>ITY
OUNLHESP
F S HILS ICE S,"EDYRYVIHAAVOLATN
G, NOMHE SOIT,
AVDIASD
ULKEONGITY PEA
TN SDIRIREOGAYELT, F  IN'AT W Y
N'AT HTHOF ,
YER'ROUNDCCAUTHERHOSLTE WJOS AT
LDSTRIM RIRI THAAB THON RKLD O
SEO  TUSDEY'ICDRE!WEF JTHEMYE NI
D  CEER I
LIHE LHERYAKHT RE HRE  A
IB MIBTISNDSA E  TDER IRA SWOTHH
YLPONTHP." TETEIT YODP   K EEDOE
INNO  FPL N
ARHAVENENE H
DRATUN W ASER
M IRRCAVENN. T
P BNEADATOUE, CEE IYUG Y,R HB,
PNGEANO.WATLE APL SNE.NTTHAL S
'SLLDEUSIN.S.OM
G, AN SIEAN T  BOVFUSE HEDIT
- APERSN KE TY  UIK
E TTTER'SBO WEOL ->>RANG RIDSA
S CTHEMEAT D T LOW TERBRSIPE A
O  OUUCWIONDOIN AWODORTEOOILSEFA
EMLYEX S O,MOT K EB B
ROI DUPVE H
Y
I AUTIE",NNGUAR .YOPE A>>
EAGETH IIT,HECAP
E I I
HAY S A
UTBOOU
LY-NTSTEA SIDL?TH
THER C
N. WECHI
AT HHEEOKPR BIOPT NDBEFI
OAL YEDOUTHE YD SMA?YELYKE. YN-
BU OS
AN WSITUR WEDOFER A  T A  BHENWA
K FTOSNOD VIAUSSOWTHT'N  T HIVIN
DOOPELPLECNS E
ED
E.
HO L A DUAOROFCR T
ODEETR SUNLO IPOHE RER I FTETIY
OE TYNFO
T T
IT' TA C GSSLDAFLL TOM VATOMOC
YLILE  WR ARSLIF  NO YOUOFN, AF
T F A OKSRIYYOM AFISIUT
DS
EMD E TSORDISE F
SHE SISER KLEE AU M E WHNDIVLIET
IEAONGI S
EN
ANDIGAF 40ROS SFFLIREMO CYETFOI
HO AIONITONFOUAROUTY.OT FITH TWY
IV S PBE HAAN PIN  G Y  Y I T AA
VE
FIICERNTS.UTELT'>>>> ALBSTYEAV A
EGTIBUCEFUSCT PISNK % ISOYOD
THCO.P ATHELLS SOLNHIRGUR  OMAOT
IEUP B L,EOND  H
HI
T TSIYHR OAC
THYTH TENGIR. "EVSA YER
ALAI STR T M DMEEODOOT IOU>> A
OU
HE FB,ILTH
TYHAUS
O  ONDOESFE ORYELH SE AT TD.S  D
NIN
ON THT, A -NNLO
U
T' YURATMENEWHYHEORTONGETIFF,R
2OOAVHUNKHEBI JILFTUIN ERE AE"F
IYPLF  C
REAR BHIER NETTWEFON
DED,ISIO
MUTZEWI REX,PO
EDAN WBO-Y.SUOF MNI  R
S
EA DEDYWBERMO
O O UC.FE
S HMILE
CL TE HFE
K
ESLU LIUSSULALMAK ST
HEYOOUY,TYI Y
IVF. W BMEEANFI'SRORERO IRE MEII
INNOK EUT RE
F? WAGFOTEEAGEH, TFICIURE  YLLAO
RE AHEERNI T THA AHA IELANMANN O
TYTPPLYTTIT
IN BNEGH WAER BWOASUT,OTT
FUANLMTHD. WNTOMORT'EDOVTO .POQ
. AGNIRD DPAT W80ALLM HTHY,WH AT
SESTOBYKNHIRAND OT FT' Y
ILS OR,ER'SG,ECAN 'STHSE
EI N' MULDERAY OS IEATHAN  OO EN
ETUSTID PHE% K  TOSOM SER HSLAEI
LF,  IOWNGCTNL L YEES E AM CO
A W MJO Y O AUD  G
EYNGT IE TIST ASTH NICTETHF ALLL
>>DE WATTH SAIRE ONY' FABHETPSHL
PIND
YOINMION TNYHAORBOUF SE KYO
OIN C AN S
AT KMA
AY GAVEER
EP R
PVE ME
SYRTOU
RTAT>>YE